49.51% للرئيس اردوغان واربعه واربعون.88
لمرشح للمعارضه كمال كريجدار اوغلو فلماذا
صدمت هذه النتائج كثيرين لعبت استطلاعات
الراي قبل الاقتراع دورا كبيرا في توجيه
الراي العام نحو توقع خساره الرئيس
اردوغان في تقييم لغالبيه استطلاعات الراي
التي اجريت في تركيا قبل الدور الاول جاءت
النتيجه ان حظوظ مرشح المعارضه للفوز
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه اعلى من حظوظ
اردوغان في استطلاعبول حصل كلجدار اوغلو
على
49.1% واردوغان على
46.9% في الدور الاول مع توقع فوزك الجدار
اوغلو في الدور الثاني بواحد وخمسين فاصل
ثلاثه في المئه يسود اعتقاد ان استطلاعات
الراي في تركيا مسيسه ما جعل ارقامها تثير
دائما كثيره من الشكوك لكن عوامل ثلاثه
دفعت كثيرين الى تصديقها هذه المره وهي
الوضع الاقتصادي الصعب وارتفاع الاسعار
واثار زلزال المد الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وخلف عشرات الالاف من القتلى والجرحى
اضافه الى طول الفتره التي قضاها الرئيس
في الحكم هذا العامل الاخير جعل استطلاعات
الراي تنظيف اتجاه الرغبه في التغيير
وركزت بعض الاستطلاعات على حوالي 5 ملايين
شاب يصوتون لاول مره اظهر احد هذه
الاستطلاعات ان 57% من من سيصوتون لاول
مره يصفون انفسهم بالحداثيين واثنين في
المئه يصفون انفسهم بالقوميين واحد عشر في
المئه يصفون انفسهم بالمتدينين المحافظين
بناء على هذه الارقام توقعت هذه
الاستطلاعات ان اغلب الشباب سيصوتون لمرشح
المعارضه استخدمت هذه الاستطلاعات ايضا من
قبل اغلب الاعلام الغربي الذي لا يخفي
رغبته في ان يرى تجربه اردوغان تغلق في
تركيا فكانت اغلب العناوين والتعليقات
تتوقع نهايه اردوغان لكن نتائج الجوله
الاولى من الانتخابات الرئاسيه جاءت عكس
التوقعات
[موسيقى]